chers collègues Madame la Commissaire
nouveau nom de vivre l'été le plus chaud
jamais enregistré c'est un signal qui
nous pousse à agir pour quoi je suis
heureux que nous adoptions de façon
consensuelle cette loi européenne sur
les énergies renouvelables qui
amplifient nos ambitions et signalent au
monde que l'Europe est sérieuse dans sa
lutte contre le réchauffement climatique
j'aurais néanmoins un commentaire
tout d'abord vis-à-vis de l'extrême
droite qui n'aime pas les renouvelables
et qui ne veut que du nucléaire et de
l'autre côté à ceux qui disent non
nucléaires et qui ne veulent que des
renouvelables je leur dis vous faites
erreur car nous avons besoin des deux
des énergies renouvelables et de
l'énergie nucléaire opposez les deux ou
omettre l'un des deux c'est ne pas être
sérieux dans la lutte contre le
réchauffement climatique l'Europe doit
miser sur toutes les formes d'énergie
propre avec mon groupe réunion Europe
nous y veillerons